معنى الان من طيران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
القادر فايز ومن القدس مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام ومن ادلب مراسل الجزيره ادهم
ابو الحسام او ارحب بكم جميعا وابدا معك
عبد القادر فايز وما اعلنه الحرس الثوري
الايراني
ازدهار على صعيد الشكل نادر ما يعلن الحرس
الثوري بهذه الطريقه بيان رسمي يخرج ويعلن
بشكل واضح عن مقتل احد المستشارين
العسكريين الايرانيين بسوريا بهجمات
اسرائيليه صحيح بان الحرس سابقا كان يقول
بان هناك من قتل في سوريا ولكنه كان يؤكد
معلومات نشرت سابقا اليوم نحن امام بيان
من قبل الحرس هو الذي يعلن عن هذه
المعلومات بشكل واضح وبشكل معلن هذا لافت
حقيقه ومهم في التوصيف على الاقل في
المضمون نحن نتحدث عن مستشار ايراني قتل
بهجمات اسرائيليه في سوريا مصطلح مستشار
هنا في الحرس الثوري يعني بالضروره نحن
نتحدث عن ضابط ايراني رسمي في الحرس
الثوري برتبه عسكريه واضحه وبخبره عسكريه
واضحه في مجال ما ويعمل داخل سوريا لذلك
لا نتحدث عن مق متطوعين لا نتحدث ربما عن
جنود في الحرس الثوري ولا نتحدث عن مستوى
متدني ربما من الرتب العسكريه نتحدث عن
مستشار وهذا يعني بان هناك رتبه عسكريه
وضابط في الحرس الثوري النقطه الثالثه بان
الحرس الثوري الايراني يقول بانه سيرد على
هذا الفعل الفهم هنا في طهران لما يجري في
سوريا حقيقه من قبل ايران بانها الحرس
الثوري يفرق في الهجمات الاسرائيليه بين
الهجمات التي تطال ربما مواقع سوريه
وجنود سوريين عسكريين سوريين وبين التي
تطال بشكل مباشر واختيال للمستشارين
العسكريين الايرانيين في الثانيه يقول
الحرس بان الرد سيكون مباشر ومعلن ورسمي
من قبل ايران هنا يكمن سؤال مهم حقيقه
ازدهار هل ان اسرائيل استهدفت موقعا
عسكريا ما وكان هذا المستشار الايراني
داخل الموقع وقتل في هذه الغاره ام ان
اسرائيل تقوم بتصفيه هذا المستشار بمعنى
انها لاحقت هذا المستشار
واقامت باغتيالها على الارض السوريه في
الحاله الثانيه نحن نكون امام ربما حدث
خطير ولكن اريد ان اشير ايضا ازدهار الى
ان الجو الاقليمي الحاكم الان وجو الملف
السوري الحاكم الان في الاقليم سيلعب دور
كبير حقيقه في تقدير ايران لعمليه الرد
على اسرائيل ولكن واضح تماما من بيان
الحرس الثوري بان الحرس الثوري يعلن عن
مقتل هذا المستشار وينهي البيان بانه سيرد
على اسرائيل نعم عبد القادر وسنتناول ايضا
كان هناك رد فعل اسرائيلي مع الياس كاران
لاحقا قبل ذلك انتقل اليك ادهم ابو حسام
تفاصيل والمعلومات التي رشحت بخصوص هذه
الهجمات
وكانت سنه الرسميه التابعه لنظام السوري
قالت انه بعد في الدقيقه السابعه عشر من
بعد منتصف الليل استهدفت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي برشقات صاروخيه باتجاه الجولان
عده مواقع جنوب غربيه العاصمه دمشق لكنها
لم تذكر عن اي خسائر بشريه سواء عناصر
سوريون او عناصر تابعه للحراسه الثوري
الايراني او فصائل المواليه لايران ولكن
مصادر المحليه ذكرت ان الضربات استهدفت
مستودعات للاسلحه والذخائر اضافه الى غرفه
عمليات تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني ولكن
لم يتثنى التاكد حينها بمقتل مستشار بعتب
عاليه او عناصر برتب عاليه تابعينا للحرس
الثوري الايراني هذه الضربه الثانيه
للمحيط العاصمه دمشق لمواقع فصائل
المواليه لايران خلال اقل من 24 ساعه
تنافذها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في محيط
دمشق نتحدث عن سته غارات جويه في اقل من
شهر نتحدث ست قرارات جويه في شهر مارس
اذار الحالي واجهتها قوات الاحتيال
الاسرائيلي عدت مواقع تابعه لنظام السوري
واخرى تابعه
فصائل موليه لايران وايضا مواقع للحرس
الثوري الايراني كان ايضا اخرها في السابع
من الشهر الحالي لاستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
استهدف شحنه اسلحه بحسب مصادر محليه
للجزيره مما ادى ايضا الى دمار كبير في
القسم الجنوبي من مطار حلب الدولي وخرج عن
الخدمه في وقتها مئات الضربات الاسرائيليه
التي واجهتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى عده مواقع خلال الاعوام الماضيه لما
الحظ على اثرها تصعيد ملحوظ بين الجانبين
عاده اسرائيل لا تعلق على موضوع الضربات
وهي ربما المره الاولى التي يصرح بها
الحرس الثوري الايراني عن مقتل احد
مستشاريه في سوريا المره الاولى في
الحالتين اسرائيل عاده لا تعلق ولكن
سنتوقف ان كان هناك روايه اسرائيليه معك
الياس كرام او ردود فعل على الاقل على
بيان الحرس الثوري الايراني
نعم ازدهار اسرائيل قلقه جدا منذ شهور من
التقارب الايراني الروسي في الساحه
الاوكرانيه لا سيما فيما يتعلق بالهجمات
التي تنفذ بالطائرات المفخخه المسيره وهذا
ربما ما يفسر الاستهدافات المتتاليه
لاسرائيل لاهداف بعينها على الاراضي
السوريه تابعه لايران كما تقول بين الحين
والاخر ولمستودعات اسلحه وذخيره وصواريخ
تقول بان النظام الايراني يوصلها الى الى
حزب الله في لبنان ويطورها على الاراضي
السوريه حتى الان اسرائيل الرسميه تلتزم
الصمت حيال ما جرى ونحن نتحدث عن الهجوم
الرابع او الخامس على الاقل في غضون هذا
الشهر الجاري وهذا يدلل على ان اسرائيل
تكثف من هجماتها لسبب ما لاهداف معينه ترى
بان هنالك ربما تكثيف للتحركات العسكريه
لهذه الميليشيات وربما لانتاج الصواريخ
الدقيقه
توصلها الى حزب الله في لبنان لذلك هذه
الاستهدافات المتكرره السؤال الان فيما
اذا كان مقتل هذا القائد الكبير في الحرس
الثوري الايراني كان مقصودا ومستهدفا
وبناء على معلومات استخباراتيه وفرها
الموساد واجهزه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ام ان وجوده كان صدفه في
الموقع العسكري الذي استهدف هذا يغير
المعادله بالكامل لكن على ضوء هذا التهديد
ما من شك فان اسرائيل سوف تتخذ خطوات
دفاعيه لا سيما على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه على خط وقف اطلاق النار في
الجولان ومن غير المستبعد ان تكون هنالك
ايضا تدابير امنيه حتى على صعيد مدينه
ايلات على البحر الاحمر لان هنالك مخاوف
لدى اسرائيل بان الحوثيين المدعومين من
ايران ربما يستخدمون طائرات مسيره تستهدف
هذه المدينه ولا نستبعد ايضا هجمات ازدهار
قد تطال ايضا الممرات البحريه التي
تستخدمها اسرائيل في البحر الاحمر للممرات
التجاريه